-Our first guest tonight
is a talented writer,
actor, and director
you know as Mac
on "It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia."
Season 2 of the show
"Mythic Quest" is streaming no
on Apple TV+ with new episodes
available on Fridays.
Let's take a look.
-You're agreeing
with everything I say
And then you're
giving in to all my demands.
-You want me to fight with you
-Yeah, but I don't want yo
to plan for it.
It has to happen organically
like it does with Poppy.
The high pressure and the
friction,
that's what turns coal
into diamonds.
-How much friction
would you like?
-You're [Bleep] useless.
I'm sorry, man.
You're fine, I guess,
as an art director or whatever
But I need someone
that challenges me.
And let's be honest,
if we went at it,
I'd turn you into a pretzel both
physically and intellectually.
-You're the boss.
-Please welcome back
to the show Rob McElhenney
How are you, Rob?
-Hello! Seth, I'm fantastic.
I'm missing that mustache
actually.
-I'm missing it as well.
I'm very happy to see you but
little disappointed
the mustache didn't come.
-I'm gonna be honest,
I'm a little disappointed
myself.
Now that I see how
glorious it was.
-You guys really had to -- a lot
of shows, a lot of productions
had to deal with
the affect of the pandemic
But you had written a season
worth of scripts
That you then had to throw out
-Yeah, yeah, we wrote
an entire season of television
and then shot the first episod
of that season
and then we shut down.
Which, we thought we'll shut
down for a couple days
and then we'll just come bac
and pick up.
And then as the weeks went b
and we realized
that's most likely
not going to happen,
we realized we had to thro
the entire season out
and start over.
But it gave us something to do
for a year.
-You also had one of the
most creative,
One of the best received
episodes that was shot
during the pandemic.
You must be pleased with how
that turned out.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
We were --
I was just so incredibly proud
of the entire crew.
To have shot something
from home.
None of us left our homes to
shoot that episode
and to have it as well-receive
as it was,
it just -- it was such a boo
to the entire show
and certainly to the
morale of the crew.
-You have a wonderful cast o
the show, and a lot of the
have a comedy background,
but you've also gotten
some actors who are know mor
for their dramatic chops
including Anthony Hopkins.
And a lot of people, I guess
ask you how that came about.
-Yeah, they can't believe it
It blows their minds.
I can't tell you how often I get
asked this question,
where people say with a specific
tone in their voice
whether they're conscious of i
or not, they'll say,
"Oh, you got Anthony Hopkins o
the show?"
or "William Hurt
is on the show?"
or "How did you get
F. Marie Abraham?"
As if it's just insane that just
because they won an Oscar
That they would want to come d
our show.
I'm like, "Well, I'll tell you
how we got them.
We wrote something pretty good
and then we paid them.
And I'm going to break some news
here on "The Seth Myers Show."
This is breaking news.
Actors love money.
They love it.
They love to get paid.
So, I don't care how many
statues you got, man,
if a good material --
piece of material comes your way
and somebody pays you enough
you'll do it.
-It's also funny because it'
not like "West World" is
less outlandish than your show
and Anthony Hopkins did that
It's just the fact
that people think comedy
is so much less valuable.
They just go, "What terrible
mistake did he make
to end up
spending time with you.
-Yes, I would love to know i
the producers of "West World
were constantly asked, "How di
you get Anthony Hopkins?"
It blows people's mind.
I think this is just a part of
the culture that maybe
we have to start to shift, Seth.
-Yes.
-Like there's just a lack of
respect for what we do.
And the truth of the matter is
you know what?
I'm going to make an
announcement right now.
It's harder to do comedy than it
is to do drama. That's it.
I'm saying it right now, ful
stop, come at me, drama people
Because on "Mythic Quest,"
we actually do both.
It's much different than "Sunny"
where we're just essentially
going for satire and laughs.
"Mythic Quest" is something that
touches a lot more
on some of the more dramatic
elements of the human condition.
And we're then heavily laude
for that, which is great.
Currently right now our review
are incredible.
And I don't want to complain
about the reviews
because we have 100% on Rotten
Tomatoes or something like that.
But I'm going to complain abou
the reviews. I take umbrage.
I take umbrage with some o
these reviews
because yes, they like it.
I'm afraid they like it
for the wrong reason.
-Interesting.
You think they are valuing the
human relationships
more than the hard part,
which is that
it's actually truly funny.
-100%.
Again, I don't want to complai
about people who like the show
but I'm going to
complain about them,
on national television
right now.
I'll read these reviews that are
glowing.
And people will say --
and we'll spend so much
Of the time talking about th
dramatic aspects of the show
And I'm like, look,
that's great in a drama.
But for a comedy, you would hope
that if it was well-liked,
it would be well-received
for the entire experience
of the show, which, of course,
at certain points will be
dramatic but we would be als
heavily lauded for the
comedy of the show.
And I believe the show is
really, really funny.
Maybe I want to take back
the respect a little bit.
You understand.
You know you're not respected.
-Yeah. None. Not even from
friends and family.
I will take a quick break,
and I hope that
during this break that
if there are any critics
who loved your show
that are watching,
they take a moment to look
in the mirror
and think about
what they've done.
We'll be right back.
-But not too long.
Don't rescind the review.
You know,
the review's already out.
-That's true. You can't take i
back, Rotten Tomato rules.
We'll be right back with mor
from Rob McElhenney.